okay let me bring you some breaking news
from malaysia the king has appointed
ismael sabri as the new prime minister
marking the return of the long-ruling
umno party he replaces muhirdin yasin
who resigned on monday yasin's coalition
fell apart over criticism that he
mishandled the coronavirus pandemic
sadly's unknown party governed malaysia
for six decades after independence but
it lost power in 2018 because of a
corruption scandal well florence louis
is joining us live now from kuala lumpur
florence first of all what more do we
know about malaysia's new prime minister
well we know that he's got the support
of 114 members of parliament out of 220
now
ismail sabri being appointed as the
prime minister of malaysia really puts
amno in a much stronger position amna
was already part of government under the
muiden yasin administration and now this
new alliance is essentially made up of
the very same parties as the previous
administration but um will now be in the
driver's seat because ismael sabri jacob
is the vice president of amnor
now
this is a position that amno has coveted
and in fact it was umno that um
brought down the muid in yasin
administration when 15 mps from amnor
decided that they would no longer
support him but it was also made in
yasin that allowed amna to come back
into power via so-called the back door
when muy danyasin who was part of the
ruling administration switched sides
and aligned himself with amno now in
terms of the policies going forward with
ismael sabri at the helm of the
leadership um analysts say they don't
expect much to change because ismael
sabri was also part of the previous
administration so the government's
handling of the pandemic um or
mismanagement if you will um because
malaysia despite a state of emergency
despite a lockdown has still been
recording record high number of new
infections and deaths um it's got one of
the highest rates of coronavirus cases
in the region well
these policies haven't worked and it has
created a lot of public anger but
analysts don't expect the policies to
change because the government will
remain much the same and we are
expecting to see the same faces in
cabinet as well now about an hour ago
there was already about there were
already about three nearly 350 000
signatures in an online petition
against um ismail sabri being appointed
as the prime minister
so
you know i'm not sure how much this
changes in terms of um policy um for
malaysia in terms of the pandemic in
terms of how it's going to handle its
economic recovery but what this does is
it does put amna in a much stronger
position than before
florence thank you very much indeed
that's florence louis bringing us up to
date from kuala lumpur